Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Ich hab dich im Fernsehen gesehen.
Schön.
Wir sitzen hier vor dem Salon, werden gleich Bücher lesen. Du hast auch Bücher gelesen. Zusammen mit älteren Damen. Hast du dich wohlgefühlt?
Nein, nicht nur ältere Damen. Es war Laura De Weck, die Moderatorin. Das ist eine junge Frau. Aber du hast natürlich nur auf Elke Heidenreich und mich geblickt. Es war ganz reizend.
Hast du auch Alkohol getrunken?
Nicht während der Sendung, aber danach muss man Alkohol trinken, denn es war ein sehr schöner Abend und es ist eine tolle Sendung. Schön, dass es so ein Format gibt, in dem solange über Bücher gesprochen werden kann, die Literatur wirklich im Mittelpunkt steht. Und es ist schon...
Ihr habt auch klassischerweise das Smartphone nochmal richtig rausgeräumt.
Ja.
Aus dem Gespräch, aus dem Leben, aus dem Alltag.
Wie man sich das mit 81-jährigen Frauen vorstellt.
Nein, Elke Heidenreich ist sehr digital unterwegs. Sie hat ein Smartphone und sie bedient es auch. Das habe ich hinter den Kulissen gesehen.
Hat sie dir ein Taxi geholt?
Nein, sie hat mir nicht ein Taxi geholt. Das war dann jemand anders. Aber Elke Heidenreich ist mitten im Leben. Es ist sehr beeindruckend zu sehen, was sie für ein Pensum dort bewältigt und wie frisch sie ist, wie offen sie ist für Konversationen. Es macht großen Spaß.
Was allerdings im Mittelpunkt stand für uns Zuschauer, sind eure beiden Frisuren.
Ja.
Elkes und Wolfgangs.
Gibt es da Parallelen oder wie meinst du?
Also sie hat es ja sehr strubbelig und so weiter. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das als Frisur noch durchgeht.
Ja, so ist es ja immer gewesen.
Man nennt es Frisur und du hast jetzt auch wieder Frisur.
Ich habe jetzt auch wieder Frisur. Die Kappe ist Gott sei Dank passé und ich bin sehr froh darüber und dachte im Schweizer Fernsehen will ich doch nicht mit Kappe sitzen. Dafür ist die Schweiz so ein bisschen zu vornehm.
Man muss der Wolfgang sehr hohe Gagen zahlen, um die Kappe abzusetzen.
Genau. Das Gerücht hören wir jetzt verbreiten. Also wer das sehen will, kann das in der Mediathek tun. Noch ein kleiner Hinweis, weil ich das letzte Mal das kurz erwähnt oder du hattest das angesprochen mit dieser Signieraktion. Da gab es jetzt manche, die nochmal gefragt haben. Also es gibt eine Anthologie, die herauskommt am 23. September. Die heißt Selbst Schuld. Die habe ich herausgegeben gemeinsam mit Ann-Christin Clusty. Und da ist auch ein Beitrag von mir drin und viele andere schreiben dort. Und wer jetzt da ein Signiertes...
Wer ist denn da?
Christian Baron, Anke Stelling, Shader Kurt. Es sind Dietmar Daert auch dabei, Sebastian Friedrich. Also es ist ein buntes Potpourri. Und es geht eben um diese Frage, woran sind wir eigentlich selbst schuld. Es geht um Familie auch, zum Beispiel, wie man sie anders denken sollte. Und ich spreche über oder schreibe über die Staatsbürgerschuld. Sind wir eigentlich dem Staat etwas schuldig? Jedenfalls, wer jetzt ein signiertes Buch haben möchte, und diesen Podcast früh genug hört, kann das also bis zum 8.9. über die Seite Autorenwelt bestellen. Autorenwelt ist eine Seite, die alle möglichen Bücher anbieten, aber auch signierte Bücher. Und wenn man das dort vorbestellt, dann können wir das noch rechtzeitig signieren.
Wie viel hast du denn signiert?
Noch keines, aber nächste Woche ist die Signieraktion. Das heißt, die brauchen dann bis zum 8.9. alle Vorbestellungen.
Kann ich noch einen Verbesserungsvorschlag machen? Nicht nur signieren, sondern auch nummerieren.
Könnte schwierig werden.
Ich hab meine alten Republiken die ersten 100 auch nummeriert. Nicht sehr konsequent, aber so ein paar haben Nummern. Und ich glaube, mit Nummern ist noch mal exklusiver.
Machen wir dann beim nächsten Mal. Das ist eine schöne Idee.
Die Holzdiele gibt es aber nicht so signiert.
Das ist ein bisschen kompliziert, weil man muss ja die Leute, die signieren, alle an einen Ort bringen und das dann auch rechtzeitig vorher anleiten. Das ist mit drei Leuten ein bisschen schwierig. Zu zweit geht das jetzt ganz gut. Aber du musst ja diese Bücher alle haben. Die müssten ja sonst erst alle mal zu mir geschickt werden und dann alle zu Ole und dann alle zu Nick Martin Sternske. Da wird es schwierig.
Da wird es schwierig, weil gedruckte Bücher. Die summieren sich schnell auf. Man denkt, sie ziehen Bücher, aber plötzlich braucht man Bizeps oder sowas.
Ja, ja.
Okay.
Aber wir glauben ja noch an das gedruckte Buch. Ich habe hier auch schon wie alle liegen.
Ich sehe auch, wie dick es ist. Erstaunlich. Es kam mir gar nicht so dick vor. Ich bin durchgeflogen.
Ja, 380 Seiten.
Ich finde es so gut.
Es ist ja großzügig gedruckt, also sagen wir. Deswegen wirkt es ein bisschen opulenter.
Ja, es entspricht dem Metier, würde ich sagen.
Ja.
Alles ein bisschen größer denken.
Thüringen.
Keine Überraschungen.
Keine Überraschungen, keine Clips, keine Notizen, nur eine Anmerkung. Wenn jetzt immer ganz viele Emotionen, könnte man ja sagen. Keine Notizen, keine Clips, keine Infos, nur Emotionen. Die Thüringer sind wütend. Ob sie es berechtigt sind oder nicht, ist ja egal. Sie sind erst mal wütend. Und ich finde, wenn man so ein Wahlergebnis sieht und die Thüringer nicht so genau kennt, darf man auch erst mal wütend sein. Weil man muss ja nicht nur auf die Thüringer wütend sein.
Ja, und auch nicht auf alle Thüringer. Manche Thüringer haben ja auch anders gewählt. Das ist ja jetzt nicht so, als die AfD 99 Prozent.
Aber 70 Prozent haben wir nicht gewählt und so. Also diese Kommentare wurden ja jetzt überall gemacht.
Man sollte es aber schon mal unterstreichen, gerade weil du doch gerne dabei bist, die alle über einen Kamm zu scheren. Und es ist ja nicht so. Also es ist ein großes Problem. Und es ist größer, als ich jetzt vor paar Jahren gedacht hätte. Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ganz Thüringen so denkt.
Aber ich bin ja da auch ein radikaler Denker.
Ach so.
In Thüringen mag die AfD ein Problem sein.
Nur...
Ich finde auch CDU wählt bescheuert. Und ich bin auch wütend auf CDU-Wähler. So, da gab es auch 30 Prozent. Ich stelle mich jetzt nicht hin und sage, naja, aber 15 Prozent haben nicht die AfD und nicht die CDU gewählt. Ich freue mich noch ein bisschen. Nein. Ich sehe dieses Wahlergebnis und denke mir, das geht so nicht. Aber ich höre die Kommentare dazu und denke mir, das geht so auch nicht. Denn mir war ganz viel Wert zu unterscheiden zwischen die Thüringer wählen, erstmal jemanden ab und irgendwann gibt es dann auch eine neue Regierung. So, dass das Wahlergebnis noch etwas damit zu tun hat, wie diese neue Regierung entsteht. Also wir werden jetzt monatelang so einen Stress erleben und am Ende wird es heißen, ja, aber das war der Wählerwille. Und dann wird sich fragen, was war jetzt der Wählerwille? Dass wir eine Konstruktion haben, in der im Hinterzimmer, weil ist ja alles ganz vertraulich, die BSW, von denen noch keiner weiß, wer das ist, mit der CDU und da wissen wir so ungefähr, wer das ist. Die würden am liebsten mit der AfD, aber dürfen halt nicht, jemand verbietet sie ihnen, keine Ahnung, also beißen sie ihnen saure Apfel. Also wir haben eine sehr große Fraktion, die in den sauren Apfel beißt, eine BSW, die wir nicht kennen, eine SPD, keine Ahnung, wer ist diese SPD, keine Ahnung. Und dann eine Stimme von den Linken, aber das ist gar nicht eine Stimme von den Linken, weil das ist nur Bodo Ramelos Stimme, weil er hat ja sein Direktmandat gewonnen im Vergleich zu den ganzen Losern aller anderen Fraktionen. Mario Vogt hat sein Direktmandat nicht geholt, Höcke auch nicht, Wolf auch nicht. Also was ist das für eine Konstellation? Es gibt hier keinen Wählerwillen, weshalb ich einen Vorschlag mache. Man sollte jetzt einfordern, dass der neue Thüringer Landtag, und das steht ja drin in der Verfassung, muss in 30 Tagen zusammentreten. So, die treten jetzt mal zusammen, besprechen dieses Wahlergebnis und kümmern sich immer einen Scheiß drum, wer als nächstes die Regierung stellt. Sondern die fragen sich erstmal, was ist das für ein Wahlergebnis? Und beauftragen irgendwen, schaffen irgendeine Struktur, um herauszufinden, was diese AfD-Wähler wollen. Dann sammelt man diese Information zusammen, was die wollen und entscheidet nichts gegen sie. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob sich eine Zeitung bereitstellen sollte, da irgendwie eine demoskopische Erhebung zu machen oder ob man eine echte Volksbefragung macht.
Wie darfst du mir das vorstellen, wenn nicht gegen sie entschieden wird, weil der Wille von AfD-Wählern könnte ja doch recht heikel sein.
Genau. Das Problem ist, in fünf Jahren ist wieder eine Wahl. Wenn man jetzt noch mal, und deswegen, wir haben ja beim letzten Mal 2014, 2019, jetzt aktuell 24, das sind ja, also eine eindeutigere Tendenz gibt es gar nicht. AfD 10%, AfD 20%, AfD 30%. So, in fünf Jahren hat die AfD 40%.
Muss man nicht.
Das sagst du. Ich sage...
Mit einer anderen Politik ist es doch möglich.
Aber mit welcher anderen Politik?
Ja, aber ich glaube nicht mit einer Politik, die jetzt fragt, was will die AfD, was wollen die AfD, weil das müsste eigentlich eine Politik sein, die jetzt so viel Interessantes Neues auf den Weg bringt, zum Beispiel was die Innenstädte anbelangt, Infrastruktur, Kinderbetreuung etc. Ja, dann muss man das mit dem Bund verhandeln, dass es dann doch dafür Geld gibt. Dann muss man jetzt die große Revolution starten, vom Osten hin zum Westen, dass die Schuldenbremse reformiert wird.
Ich muss dir ins Wort fallen, um mich zu korrigieren. Den Spruch, es gibt kein Geld, den mache ich ab heute nicht mehr. Gut, weil wir lesen ja, dass es Geld gibt.
Ja, es gibt Geld, genau. Also es gibt Geld.
Es gibt ja Geld.
Man muss es von irgendwo holen. Da gibt es verschiedene Möglichkeiten. Eine bekommen wir heute auch noch mal präsentiert von Julia Friedrichs. Und deshalb würde ich sagen, es muss eine andere Politik her, damit die Wähler nicht mehr so etwas wollen. Denn die Frage ist ja, wollen sie das überhaupt? Und dann würde ich doch sagen, wir springen zu einem anderen Clip, den ich eigentlich für später mir aufgemacht habe. Ausnahmsweise will ich gleich sagen. Werden wir uns jetzt einen Clip anhören aus der heutigen Show? Ich bin bekanntlich kein Fan dieser Sendung. Und mir geht es jetzt auch gar nicht darum, was die wieder tolles gemacht haben. Sondern worum es jetzt überhaupt nur geht, ist, dass wir den Mann zuhören, der da von Fabian Köster auf der Straße interviewt wird. Fabian Köster ist im Osten unterwegs.
Leute auf der Straße, das sind die wichtigsten jetzt.
Und fragt jetzt einfach mal, wie er denn das so kurz vor der Wahl einschätzt. Wir hören uns jetzt mal an und dann fragen wir uns auch, ob man mit Demoskopie, ob man mit irgendetwas noch weiterkommen kann bei solchen Leuten.
Wie finden Sie denn Herrn Höcke? Ja, ein bisschen.
Also ich bin mehr für den Coopella und für die Frau Weigel. Das ist natürlich eine spitze Kraft, da muss ich sagen.
Also Sie sind für die Moderaten, die dann gesteuert werden von Herrn Höcke?
Da ziehe ich echt einen Hut, die haben auch echt was drauf. Und Heike ist natürlich ein bisschen speziell, aber nicht schlecht.
Bisschen speziell sagen die einen, Faschisten sagen die anderen.
Faschisten, das ist ja alles, wo holen die das her? Also was hat das alles mit Nazi zu tun? Überhaupt nichts mehr.
Wusstest du, wenn man sich so seine Reden anhört?
Ja, wenn man auf dem Boden bleiben will.
Denkmal der Fande, hat er ja, das wurde rausgemacht.
Das ist alles Hirngespinsel von den Altparteien.
So, also, diese Leute sind natürlich amüsant für uns, als würden wir so in den Zoo gehen und sagen, ach guck mal, der ist aber besonders zottelig, der Löwe. Ganz schön gefährlich, aber er ist ja contained, glauben wir. Nur, man muss sich halt mit solchen Leuten jetzt auseinandersetzen.
Aber wie ist das auf der Grundlage möglich? Also ich kann ja, wenn jetzt jemand sagt, ich habe folgende Ideologie oder so, formulieren das die Leute nicht, aber wenn man, wenn sie sagen würden, das ist das Problem mit Migration, dann kann man sagen, nein, das ist kein Problem mit Migration. Im Gegenteil, es liegt eher in dem und dem. Ja, dann kann ich mit denen in eine Debatte reingehen, aber mit jemandem, der eigentlich nur noch unter einem Performancegedanken. Ich spiele das auch extra ab, weil du immer so starkgemacht hast. Jetzt in letzter Zeit die Show ist doch alles und so. Der nur unter dem Performancegedanken so sagt, ja, die Weidel und Krupalla, das ist so, der Höcke ist so ein bisschen speziell. Also wie man sich so in einer Band so seine Lieblingsmusiker aussuchen und sagt, ja, der Frontman, der gefällt mir eigentlich ganz gut, der Bassist bisschen langweilig, aber hier der hinten auch noch toll. Also das ist ja so interessant, dass wir es hier mit jemandem zu tun haben, der offenbar keine Wertegrundlage mehr hat, auf der er irgendeine politische Entscheidung trifft. Sondern das eine ist das Performative und das andere ist so ein gelebter Hass auf Migranten und alle anderen, aber ohne dass er das auch noch als Ideologie sehen will. Also das ist ja auch ein Unterschied zu jetzt einem Faschismus, italienischer oder deutscher Prägung der 20er, 30er Jahre, wo ganz klar man sich für diesen Faschismus auch entschieden hat und das auch sehr transparent war. Man hat ja nicht gesagt, naja, im Ende sind wir es ja gar nicht. Sondern hier sagt man so, naja, gut, also der Höcke, der sagt da schon mal, aber das hat ja, was hat das damit zu tun? Also es gibt überhaupt gar keine Grundlage mehr, weder eine moralische, eine wertfundierte Grundlage, noch irgendein politisches Analyseinstrument, mit dem dieser Mann überhaupt in der Lage ist, einzuschätzen, für was ein Höcke steht.
Also die Bandbreite der Antworten ist entgegen der derzeit publizierten Meinung groß. Wir haben auch das letzte Mal im Podcast gesagt, dieser Mann unter seinem Apfelbaum ist ja nicht zu erreichen. Ja, stimmt, wenn man in dem bisherigen Mustern bleibt, aber nicht wenn man aus ihm ausbricht. Ich habe mich ja schon mehrfach autorisiert, indem ich sage, ich bin selbst Thüringer. Das heißt, wenn ich solche Leute auf der Straße treffe und ich biete jetzt zwei Möglichkeiten an, die eine ist totaler Quatsch, sage ich dazu, die andere nicht. So, die die totaler Quatsch ist, ich selber gehe mit meinem 1,90 Meter, größer als 1,90, einfach auf den Zu und sage, so können sie hier nicht rumstehen. Stehen sie stramm, trainieren sie mehr, sie sind zu schwer, ihr Bauch, das gefällt uns nicht. So sehen Deutsche nicht aus. Also ich würde ihn komplett konfrontieren. Er glaubt, ja, das ist irgendwie lustig. So, Kropalla ein bisschen cooler zu finden als Höcke, weil Höcke irgendwie uncool gilt oder was weiß ich. Höcke hat seinen Wahlkreis nicht gewonnen, das sagt ja auch einiges. Typischerweise, wenn man bekannt ist im Funk und Fernsehen, gewinnt man seine Wahlkreise. Deswegen will man den Funk und Fernsehen. So funktioniert das eigentlich. Dort machen die Leute und sagen sich, ich will nur diese amüsante Seite der AfD, die so sagt, was der Schulz macht, ist blöd. Sobald es konkret wird und sei es nur in der Konkretisierung einer Person, sind sie erschrocken. Und sehr viele Thüringer sind gerade erschrocken darüber, was passiert. Denn die prognostizierten Texte in der New York Times, die Nazis sind zurück und diesmal die echten, sind geschrieben worden. Also das kann man weltweit jetzt zitieren und nachlesen. Das heißt, diese Typen, die könnte man einfach konfrontieren. Ich könnte das. Ich bin Thüringer. Ich kann einfach nach Magdala hinfahren und die Leute, die da eine Bratwurst kaufen wollen und einen AfD-Spruch machen, aufziehen damit, dass man sich so die Nazis aber nicht vorgestellt hat. Sie sind kein Nazi. Sie können das gerne sich wünschen, aber da müssen sie erst mal in sich investieren. Also die einfach ihnen zeigen, dass sie ab sofort zu der Loser-Seite gehören. Sie dachten, sie sind auf der Seite der Sieger, wenn sie Nazis wählen. Nein. Nazis wollen aufrechte, durchstrukturierte, geformte Menschen. Und es ist keiner. Er sieht sich auf der sicheren Seite.
Die Leute, die auf dem Stadtfest durch die Gegend laufen und sagen, warum sind hier so viele Ausländer? Und mehr ist es ja nicht, was die anzubieten haben, außer ein bisschen Hass.
Genau. Damit wäre ich jetzt sehr aus einem Muster ausgebrochen. Also ich habe noch keinen anderen Podcast gehört, in dem das so kommentiert wurde.
Ich auch nicht. Man kann darüber nachdenken, ob es Gründe hat. Aber wie ist der seriöse Vorschlag?
Der seriöse Vorschlag ist, auch ihn zu konfrontieren. Und zwar mit der Ansage, sie haben offenbar AfD gewählt. Vielleicht können sie es einsehen, dass die AfD nicht zwingend jetzt mitregieren kann, weil dann schreibt die New York Times Texte, da passiert ja gar nichts mehr.
Du glaubst doch nicht, dass der Mann sich von der New York Times beeindrucken lässt.
Naja, das ist halt der Punkt. Und jetzt kommt die Konfrontation. Man muss ihm sagen, wir kennen ihr Medienverhalten. Sie lehnen gerne zurück in der Sonne, sitzen unter irgendwelchen Apfelbäumen, auf ihrer Terrasse, was auch immer. Sie haben Spaß am Leben offenbar. Und sie konsumieren gerne Informationen zum Thema Politik, insbesondere wenn sich über irgendwie lustig gemacht wird. Und dann muss man ihm sagen, in Thüringen wird genau gar nichts passieren, solange sie sich nicht dazu verhalten haben. Wenn sie weiterhin einfach nur konsumieren, was auf TikTok los ist, wird in Thüringen in zehn Jahren keine Regierung haben.
Ja, aber ich sehe nur nicht, dass der Mann darauf reagieren wird. Der ist ja in einer Dose liegen, Aparthei und deswegen freut sich noch daran.
30 Prozent AfD-Wähler. Also die AfD in die Regierung geht offenbar nicht. Ja, so Ruprecht Polens hat diesen kleinen Tweet gemacht. Die haben zu 55 Prozent AfD und BSW gewählt, also müssen die beiden jetzt auch regieren. So, jetzt haben wir natürlich ein Semsrott Buch gelesen und haben gesagt, nee, aus verantwortungsvoller Sicht und so weiter. Höcke wurde angesprochen von den Journalisten, ja, also sie als Faschist und so weiter. Und der Höcke hat es sofort zurückgegeben mit, ja, sie werden doch jetzt nicht 30 Prozent der Wähler diffamieren wollen. So im Sinne von, also ich erkenne gerne an, dass ich ein Faschist bin, aber doch nicht meine 30 Prozent Wähler, oder? So, und jetzt haben wir doch dieses Phänomen, alle Kommentatoren, alle Journalisten kommentieren gerade was Politiker tun. Niemand kommentiert, was Leute in den Medien tun. Und damit meine ich, Leute, die vor Kameras stehen, bekannt aus Funk und Fernsehen, die irgendwas sagen, wie Bettina Schaußen, 85 Jahre nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg beginnen, haben wir jetzt wieder Faschisten in Thüringen. So, ja, also ziemlich harte Kommentierung, aber keine Konfrontation. Denn das kann man erst mal einfach so sagen. Und dann kann man halt daneben stehen und sagen, oh, das finde ich aber blöd, oh, keine Ahnung. Wenn man eh schon den Stinkefinger draußen hatte, dann macht man ihn halt noch größer.
Ich sehe nicht bei jemanden, der, also du kannst eine Konfrontation herstellen bei Leuten, die noch für ein Argument offen sind. Aber du kannst bei jemanden, der auf dem Marktplatz feichsend dasteht und sagt, ja, der Weidel macht das eigentlich ganz gut, der Höcke ein bisschen speziell. Da glaube ich, kann man kaum noch eine sinnvolle Konfrontation herstellen. Gerade da.
Ich sehe gerade da, man muss den Weg noch suchen. Aber es ist wie 20 Kinder in der Klasse und du sagst, Klassenfahrt, sucht euch aus, wohin. Wenn ihr euch nicht einigen könnt, fahren wir nicht. Ja, die Verlierer-Seite muss involviert sein.
Genau, du willst ja eigentlich gerade Folgendes durchbrechen. Die sehen die Politik als ein Spiel an, als eine Unterhaltung.
Genau. Die konsumieren das.
Die konsumieren das Smartphone und sagen, oh, da hat's die Weide dem Schulz aber mal wieder gegeben.
Ganz genau, ja.
Und man muss eigentlich ihnen klar machen, dass es nicht nur das Spiel ist, sondern dass es eigentlich ihr Leben betrifft. Das heißt, man muss also diese vierte Wand durchbrechen. Aber dass das tatsächlich bei ihm ankommt, ging ja nur, wenn man sagt, schon ab sofort bekommst du auch eine Bezahlkarte und bekommst kein Bargeld mehr. Dann weißt du mal, wie das ist, wenn man Flüchtling ist.
Also Demokratie muss hergestellt werden. Sie ergibt sich nicht aus dem Wahlergebnis. Man kann jetzt nicht einfach kommen und sagen, wir haben zwar festgestellt, FDP und Grüne haben sich super verstanden. Sie haben eine Fortschrittskoalition mit der SPD, aber als wir beide sind zusammen größer als die Kanzlerfraktionen und so weiter. Also dieses Gefüge. So, drei Jahre später stellen wir fest, nee, hat nicht funktioniert, ist auch total verhasst. Die CDU trampelt auch noch mit drauf, weil irgendwie dieser Merkel muss weg Spruch komplett vergessen wurde. Die AfD hat Merkel gehasst, nicht die Ampel. Die Ampel wurde einfach nur an Merkels Stadt eingehört. Aber es war Merkel. Dieser ganze Frust, dieser ganze Ärger, dieses ganze Ich trainiere mir jetzt Medienverhalten ein, mit dem ich, wenn mir eine Kamera ins Gesicht gehalten wird, schockiere, in dem ich sage, ich finde eigentlich ganz okay und so. Das ist aus dieser Merkel-Zeit, dass die CDU jetzt einfach daneben steht und sagt, ja kein Wunder, wenn die Ampel so eine Politik macht, dass die AfD so stark ist. Und alle Journalisten daneben stehen und sagen, das stimmt irgendwie, ja, der Scholz kommt echt schlechte Politik. Das ist doch bekloppt. Also es wurde jetzt ein Landtag gewählt. Aus diesem Landtag ergibt sich, und das müssen jetzt alle einsehen, keine sinnvolle Regierungskoalition. Nicht nach den alten Mustern. Ist nicht möglich. Und deswegen kann man das jetzt auch nicht einfach machen. Dass Journalisten jetzt einfach, ah, es ist vertraulich, okay, dann warten wir einfach mal ab, was passiert. Und dann soll ein Koalitionsvertrag rauskommen, in dem irgendwie geklärt wird, wer hat welchen Posten. Und dann gibt Rammelow noch, aber es ist keine linke Stimme. Ja, also die Brandmauer zur Linken darf halten, weil es ist ja die Direktmandatsstimme von Bodo Rammelow, die das dann ergibt. Und das soll dann 40 Prozent AfD in fünf Jahren verhindern. Das ist doch absurd, solche Gedanken. Also man hat jetzt einen Landtag gewählt, der Landtag wird zusammenkommen. Wir haben ja gesehen, in Thüringen, das ist kein verbranntes Land. Die Leute sitzen da lustig auf dem Marktplatz und so. Die müssen heute nicht regiert werden. Die müssen auch nächstes Jahr nicht regiert werden. Die schaffen es auch 2026 und 2027 ohne eine Regierung. Oder mit einer Geschäftsführung oder was auch immer. Aber jetzt eine Regierung zu bilden und damit wieder, und das ist das Eigentliche, die AfD zur Opposition zu erklären, ist ein Fehler. Und den darf man jetzt nicht zu schnell machen.
Ist das nicht falsch, ja.
Und wenn der Landtag jetzt feststellt, hier ist aber Eile geboten, dann müssen sich halt mal Mehrheiten für einzelne Entscheidungen finden. Aber jetzt irgendwie neue Minister zusammenzubauen und was auch immer dann ein Kabinett aufzustellen und der AfD wieder dieselbe Gelegenheit zu geben, wie die letzten drei Male, dagegen Opposition zu sein. Einfach so.
Ja, dieser Modus für Wendy funktioniert nicht wieder.
Das kann nicht sein, obwohl die mediale Sehnsucht groß ist.
Und man hätte gerne wieder Personen, man hätte gerne wieder ein Schauspiel, das klar zu beobachten ist, so wie man ja auch bei allen anderen Sachen immer so versucht, jetzt ein paar Leute zu haben, die man auf der Bühne beobachten kann. Und das ist der Wunsch, der jetzt natürlich da ist.
Also ich freue mich alleine auf so ein Szenario, weil das mal bedeutet, dass Journalisten Politik-Journalismus machen und sie nicht einfach beim Ministerbüro anrufen können, weil es ist gerade kein Minister im Amt. Der Landtag entscheidet. Da muss man sich halt mal anschauen, was der Landtag da macht. Und die AfD-Wähler müssen dann reingezwungen werden in Mitbestimmung.
Wir sprechen ja jetzt einen Tag, nachdem es einen versuchten Terroranschlag in München gab. Und diese Fälle mehren sich, ja.
Da bin ich wieder nicht gut eingelesen.
Nein, man braucht es ja nicht einzulesen. Also nach allem, was man bis jetzt weiß, kann natürlich sein, dass das gleich überholt ist, weil es neue Informationen gibt. Handelt es sich da um einen 18-jährigen, ich weiß gerade nicht, aus welchem Land er kommt. Na, aus welchem er zuvor kam. Jedenfalls gibt es also diesen versuchten Anschlag. Also da läuft jemand mit einem Gewehr durch die Gegend in München, wird dann von der Polizei erschossen, bevor dort Größeres passiert. Und es ist ja doch ganz interessant, dass wir so eine neue Welle des Terrorismus erleben, der sich diese Welle, ist aber anders, die sieht nicht mehr so aus, wie wir das vom 11. September kennen, also mit einer großen Gruppe, die da agiert und dann solche Großprojekte, terroristischen Großprojekte durchsetzt, sondern wir haben es jetzt mit Leuten zu tun, die alleine mit dem Messer oder dem Gewehr oder der Pistole losziehen und schlimme Dinge machen. Oder kurz davor sind das zu tun und dann von der Polizei noch im letzten Moment bestoppt werden.
Hier greift übrigens das Präventionsparadox. Obwohl wir, wie Adam Tuß, sogar mittlerweile in Mickey Beisenherz Podcasts sagt, einen massenmörderischen Krieg Israels gegen die Bevölkerung von Gaza haben. Und unendliche Hass und Wut auf die westliche Welt, also viel größer als vor dem 11. September 2001, haben wir es trotzdem nicht mit großen Terrorlagen zu tun, weil die verhindert werden. Also ich glaube, hier ist, ja, aber es gibt ja Terror.
Es gibt auch abgesagte Taylor's-Wolf-Konzerte.
Ja, aber es liegt halt keiner in Großstädten im Flugzeug.
Ja, ich würde aber sagen, der Terror hat sich verändert. Man kann das auch im Übrigen nachhören bei dem Anne Will-Podcast, den ich hier wirklich mal empfehle. Nicht, weil ich alles da teile, was da gesagt wird, aber zumindest die Diagnose finde ich interessant von dem Terrorismus-Experten Neumann. Der ist ja auch CDU-Mitglied und deswegen gibt es da gewisse geistige Beschränkungen. Und dann, wenn es um die Möglichkeiten der Prävention geht, das würde ich nicht so teilen. Aber was er doch beschreibt und was man ja auch in vielen anderen Texten nachlesen konnte, ist folgendes. Es findet eine sehr schnelle Radikalisierung heute statt, von immer jünger werdenden Männern, manchmal auch Frauen, schon ab 13, 14 Jahren. Diese Radikalisierung findet sehr häufig über das Smartphone statt. Das heißt, der sogenannte islamische Staat agiert gar nicht mehr direkt. In erster Linie man muss in irgendeine Moschee gehen, die nicht so richtig kontrolliert wird, wo der Verfassungsschutzverband Verdacht hat und dort trifft man sich. Nein, oftmals ist es sogar so, dass es fast gar keine analogen Treffen gibt, sondern man hat Asylbewerber da, die sind häufig Asylbewerber, wie er sagte, die also relativ perspektivlos irgendwo da sitzen, dann sich über Telegram und andere Kanäle radikalisieren und dann geschehen plötzlich solche Einzelaktionen, weil der islamische Staat ihnen sagt, ihr seid doch da, wo unsere Feinde sind, ihr seid doch umgeben von Juden und Christen und anderen Ungläubigen, also macht, was ihr machen könnt. Und dann geht das eben dazu über, dass sie morden, und zwar ganz schnell mit einer Messe oder einer Pistole, oder mit einem Hammer, was ganz schwer einzuhägen ist. Und das ist ja ein riesen Problem, das sich da stellt, weil das natürlich viel, viel schwieriger noch zu kontrollieren ist, wie findet da wo gerade eine Radikalisierung statt. Und das bedeutet aber auch, dass man, wenn man über Lösungen nachdenkt, sehr differenziert vorgehen muss. Aber man kann schon auch von einem Versagen sprechen und nicht von einem großen Politikversagen, sondern wenn wir ja hören bei einigen, die jetzt gefasst wurden oder die auch gemordet haben, dass da IS-Fahnen rumhingen, dass die plötzlich wo abgebogen sind und da nicht rechtzeitig Hinweise gegeben wurden oder denen nicht rechtzeitig nachgegangen worden ist. Dann ist das ein großes gesellschaftliches Problem. Also dass wir diese Rückkehr des Terrorismus haben, der jetzt so ganz punktuell ist. Es ist eigentlich so eine Art Influencer-Terrorismus. Also die Terroristen über Telegram sagen, ja, du bist so wie ich und du kannst auch für die Sache kämpfen. Nimm doch einfach ein Messer, do it yourself und geh hinaus. Und diese Art der Radikalisierung, die da jetzt stattfindet, ist natürlich extremst gefährlich, weil man auch gar nicht sagen kann, ja, folgende Lösung ist jetzt angebracht. Oh, doch. Nein, nicht diese Einhebel-Umlegen-Diskussion, dass man jetzt einfach sagt, wir hören mit der Migration auf und dann haben wir dieses Problem eingereicht. Also das ist ja ein bisschen so, wie wenn man sagt, es gibt viele Unfalltote, deswegen verbieten wir den Verkehr oder sowas. Ja, das wäre ja unsinnig. Aber das ist ja gerade das, worauf sich alle so stürzen. Und wir können uns mal einen Beitrag hier anhören. Friedrich Merz, der Erste, in einer Rede in Brandenburg, sich nochmal von der AfD absetzt und dann sagt, ja, die hier sind und ja auch fast alle einen deutschen Pass haben. Und die sind ja auch toll integriert. Aber dann spricht er quasi über die, die jetzt neu gekommen sind in den letzten Jahren. Interessanterweise klammert die Union ja immer die ukrainischen Flüchtlinge dabei aus, also das ist ja, wenn sie von diesem Migrationsdruck, den es da angeblich gibt, redet, müsste sie die ja auch mit benennen. Das macht sie aus Gründen nicht. Und dann gibt es plötzlich eine solche Rede.
Schulen an, schaut euch die Wohnraumsituation an, schaut euch die Universitäten an, schaut euch die Krankenhäuser an, schaut euch die Arztpraxen an, schaut euch an, was das für Konsequenzen hat, wenn ein Land durch Migration überfordert wird.
Also, diesen selben Spruch könnte man als Mike Josef, Oberbürgermeister von Frankfurt auch machen, indem man sagt, schaut euch mal die Schulen an, schaut euch mal die Krankenhäuser an, schaut euch mal die, was auch immer, Behörden an, die so ein paar Amtszimmer noch mit Publikumsverkehr haben, alles überfordert. So, warum? Naja, weil Frankfurt halt eine Stadt ist, die einfach, wenn jetzt nicht Corona ist oder so, pro Jahr um mehrere tausend Einwohner wächst. Was ist die Lösung? Naja, man baut halt Infrastruktur nach. Eigentlich das einfachste der Welt. Das muss ich halt die Waage halten. Friedrich Merz hat ja explizit schon auf Twitter geschrieben, in den Schulen ist zu viel, also nicht zu wenig Lehrer, sondern zu viele Schüler. Also er hat das Argument schon mal undifferenziert gemacht und grundsätzlich von zu vielen Schülern gesprochen. So, als könnten wir was gegen Schüler tun im Sinne von ja, also wir können uns jetzt, wir können die Kinderarbeit wieder wieder öffentlich die Schulpflicht nicht mehr leisten. Ein paar müssen jetzt doch wieder arbeiten gehen, so weil die Schulen sind zu voll. Ja, also so gesagt. Ist ja völlig absurd. Für Deutschland gilt doch Migration ist nicht das Problem. Wir brauchen Migration. Also die Altenrepublik geht jetzt los, kurz und knapp. Aber wenn man bei Lands im Podcast hört, dass da Gespräche geführt werden mit irgendwelchen Typen, die so ein richtig hardcore islamistisches Leben führen, in Hamburg, und man fragt die dann, ja warum lebt ihr nicht da und da und da? Dann sagen die, nee, aus diesen hardcore islamischen Ländern sind wir rausgeflogen. Die akzeptieren uns da nicht. Aber in Deutschland akzeptieren wir sie. Dann heißt das doch, ja, die Diskussion wird hart und sehr streng, aber wir haben hier zu viel Freiheit. Menschen können zu sehr leben, wie sie wollen, selbst wenn das in ihrem nahen Umfeld, ihre Ehrenfrauen, ihre Kinder, zu sehr in so ein islamistisches Bild reindrängt und sie dann sogar glauben, sie müssten damit nicht nur missionieren, sondern auch noch gewalttätig und so da irgendwie eingreifen. So, diese Art von Radikalisierung, die dazu führt und die wir einfach laufen lassen, hat natürlich ganz viel mit diesen medialen Funktionsweisen, wie du es jetzt beschrieben hast, zu tun. Wir haben doch diese Studien jetzt alle dargelegt bekommen. Junge, Frauen kriegen also wirklich große Probleme medizinischer Natur mit ihrer Ernährung, weil sie sich an Facebook und Instagram falsch orientieren. Die AfD-Wähler in Thüringen sind von TikTok radikalisiert. Die haben eine Unzufriedenheit, die kann man nicht diskutieren, jedenfalls nicht in den bekannten Mustern. Was will man denen noch mal die Mietpreisbremse erklären? Das ist ja völlig aussichtslos. Jetzt gibt es sehr viele unausgesprochene Themen, in denen diese Radikalisierung auch stattfindet. Das Ausmaß ist ja wirklich beeindruckend. Wir in Deutschland haben doch gesagt, wir haben keine weiten Rohstoffe, außer das, was in unseren Köpfen steckt, also müssen wir das formen. Also sagen wir jungen Menschen im sehr wichtigen Alter, 21 bis 25, machen eine Ausbildung, lernen irgendwas, geh studieren. Sechs Stunden am Tag musst du dich damit beschäftigen und fünf Jahre später bist du ein, was weiß ich, Super Mint Ingenieur, kannst plötzlich Hochhäuser bauen, kannst irgendwas. Also hier steht alles zur Verfügung. Du musst dich nur sechs Stunden am Tag für vier Jahre mit irgendwas befassen. So, wenn dann Jonathan Hyde schreibt, die jungen Leute haben acht Stunden am Tag TikTok an und zwar über Jahre, dann führt das zu etwas. Und wenn ich dann schon wieder die Diskussion sehe, dass die New Yorker Gouverneurin im Podcast bei Hart vorgesetzt und denen erklärt, wir ziehen aus dem, was in diesem Buch steht, Konsequenzen und verbieten konsequent in der Schule TikTok. Nicht zu Hause, das können wir ja nicht, aber wenigstens in der Schule. Wir wollen jetzt nicht auch noch, dass das unser Ausbildungssystem aufgefressen wird, von dieser Aufmerksamkeitslogik. So, und dann gibt es so viel, das darf man jetzt nicht überstürzen, das ist neue Technologie, das muss man erstmal ausprobieren, es ist ja nicht alles schlecht und so. Nein, ich bin sehr dafür, dass wir hier jetzt mal, auch wir mit der Thüringer Erfahrung jetzt, radikal reingehen. Sechs Stunden am Tag TikTok zu 55 Prozent nur AfD-Content als politischen Content, das geht einfach nicht.
Ja, oder islamischer Staat.
Ja, und da ist mir scheißegal, was ein Migrant macht und es mir auch scheißegal, was eine Ampel macht. Das individuelle Medienverhalten von diesen Leuten, die was auch immer AfD wählen, das geht einfach nicht. Da ist der Ansatzpunkt.
Nur ist die Sache ja so, wenn Leute in Schulen sind, dann können sie ja entsprechend betreut werden und dann kann man dort auch etwas durchsetzen. Wir haben es ja jetzt offenbar, aufgrund dieser sogenannten Überforderung, mit sehr vielen Leuten zu tun, die Ewigkeiten in Flüchtlingsräumen rumhängen. Niemand kümmert sich recht um sie und dann haben sie ihr Smartphone, gehen zu TikTok.
Wir verkraften ihnen noch Zeit für TikTok.
Ja, und sind dann bei Telegram irgendwann so radikalisiert, dass sie zum Messerblock laufen. Und das ist ja dann aber ein großes Personalproblem eigentlich und auch wirklich eine große Herausforderung, weil es ja ganz, ganz schwer ist, weil die meisten Leute, also deswegen, mir wurde jetzt paar Mal in E-Mails geschrieben, ja, aber es ist immer die ökonomische Situation. Ich weiß, dass die ökonomische Situation dazu beiträgt. Und ich weiß auch, dass wenn jemand aus Syrien flieht und Chefarzt einer Klinik war und jetzt hier Chefarzt einer Klinik wird, dann wird er vermutlich nicht mit dem Messer durch die Gegend rennen, sondern höchstens mit dem Skalpell im OP-Saal. Aber man kann nicht, um zu operieren, meinte ich natürlich. Also man kann natürlich nicht alles auf die ökonomische Situation zurückführen. Denn es gibt ganz viele Menschen, denen geht es sehr schlecht in Deutschland, die aber Gott sei Dank keine Gewalttaten verüben. Dass es einen gewissen Zusammenhang gibt, ist völlig klar. Und deswegen ist ja die Frage, was muss eigentlich politisch getan werden? Das ist ja eine Frage auch auf kommunaler Ebene vor allem, dass eine solche Radikalisierung zum Beispiel in Flüchtlingsheimen nicht stattfinden kann. Und das bedeutet ja einfach, dass dort gleich eine Integration stattfinden muss, auch für jene, die dann keine Perspektive haben, längere Zeit hier zu bleiben. Dass die nicht einfach nur in einer Wartestellung da sind und nicht mehr Gesellschaft erfahren, sondern nur noch völlig vereinsamt individualisiert mit ihrem Smartphone kommunizieren können. Und das wäre ja eigentlich die große Herausforderung. Was aber passiert ist ja, dass man alle, die jetzt einen Migrationshintergrund haben, plötzlich unter einen Generalverdacht stellt. Alle, die muslimischen Glauben sind, unter Generalverdacht stellt. Und man auch bereit ist plötzlich da, wo jetzt eine Partei kurz davor ist, an die Macht zu kommen im Osten, die den Rechtsstaat aushöhlen will, hören wir einen Söder, der Folgendes auf der Bühne sagt.
Ich habe irgendwo gelesen, stand irgendwo eine Anweisung. Wenn er sich wehrt, dann lasst ihn mal. Wer sich weigert, einen Rechts zu folgen, der muss in Abschiebehaft genommen werden, in Abschiebearrest. Ist denn das auf Dauer wirklich sinnvoll, dass jeder gegen unser Land einen Klageanspruch, einen einklagbaren Anspruch hat, zu entscheiden, ob er hier kommt, müsste nicht endlich wieder das deutsche Volk, die deutsche Politik selber entscheiden können, ob, wie viel und wer kommt. Wir müssen dieses Asylrecht ändern. Ändern und wieder die Kontrolle selbstständig übernehmen. Meine Damen und Herren, nicht die Gerichte sollen entscheiden, sondern die Politik soll sagen, was sie sich vorstellt, wer und wen wir in unserem Land stärken können.
Ja, blöde, dass wir einen Rechtsstaat haben.
Ich finde, hier müssen wir anschließen an Sehgewohnheiten, die wir kennen. Diese Clips ab sofort das Audio runter dimmen auf 16-Bit und nur noch schwarz-weiß senden. Damit man versteht, was hier passiert. Das, was er inhaltlich sagt, ist totaler Nonsens. Überlagene Nationen haben sich sehr schön aufgedröselt. Amerika hat auch ein Migrationsproblem. Die Grenze zu Mexiko sind irgendwie ein Fluss und 1000 Kilometer. Deutschland 4000 Kilometer Außengrenze. Unterschiedliche Juristikation, egal, wo man hinblickt. Man weiß gar nicht, wie muss man jetzt mit Österreich darüber reden, um dann eine Zurückweisung, also wir greifen ja dann auch ins österreichische Recht ein und sagen, du bleibst mal schön in Österreich. So, wir zwingen dich jetzt Österreich auf. Geht das überhaupt? Ja, das ist doch absurd. Das ist doch völlig bescheuert, so was zu fordern. Also diese ganzen, was ich allerdings, also wir suchen jetzt die konstruktive Wende. Wenn man solche Clips hört, Markus Söder ist plötzlich das geltende Recht egal, selbst das Grundgesetz. Er ist bereit, da Änderungen vorzunehmen. Da würde ich sagen, dann sollten wir das aufgreifen. Die Frage ist halt, warum jetzt die Migranten darunter leiten sollten. Wir können ja genauso gut sagen, der reichste Mann der Welt hat einen Service, der die Leute kognitiv vergiftet. Wir schalten ihn ab, so wie in Brasilien. Irgendwer fliegt mit seinem Privatjet und möchte halt einen schönen Tag in Paris haben, wird festgenommen. So, weißt du? Und so will ich das in Deutschland auch. Ich will eine Diskussion darüber, was passiert. Muss man wirklich erst die Ukraine überfallen mit dem Angriffskrieg, um hier persona non grata zu sein? Oder reicht es irgendwie, die ganze Jugend des Landes zu vergiften? So, und da will ich jetzt, dass da mal das Gesetz entsprechend geändert wird, damit hier diese Grenzüberschritte nicht mehr stattfinden.
Die medialen Diskussionen verlaufen etwas anders. Wir hören einen Ausschnitt aus einer Markus Lanz Sendung.
Danke, liebe Journalisten.
Markus Lanz, vor allem schlimm, gerade sehr schlimm. Ich verdanke diesen Clip nur der Kocher. Ich hab mir nicht die ganze Sendung reingezogen. Ich bin nicht...
Ich bin gespannt.
Ich will sagen, ich bin nicht wahnsinnig, aber ich wollte sagen, ich könnte diesen Podcast dann nicht mehr machen, wenn ich jetzt auch noch alle Lanz Sendungen mir angucken müsste. Aber wir sehen jetzt, also Lanz oder hören Markus Lanz. Und da ist Jan von Acken, der neue Chef der Linken.
Der ist älter als Waltz und so, ne?
Wirklich?
Der ist 62 oder 63. Ich war auch überrascht. Ich dachte, der ist doch so irgendwie Mitte 40 oder so. Nein, der ist so alt wie Brad Pitt. Also natürlich ein schlechter Vergleich.
Ja, gut. Wir hören jetzt also Lanz.
Für beispielsweise niedrige Mieten. Wie passt das zu Ihrer Aussage, wir werden niemals eine, wie auch immer geartete, Obergrenze für Migration festlegen, sondern wir werden die Grenzen, wir werden Deutschland offen halten und lassen damit zu, dass genau dort, wo unsere Klientel sitzen, ein sehr harter Kampf, ein Wettkampf, ein Konkurrenzkampf, um genau das entsteht, nämlich bezahlbaren Wohnraum. Wie passt das zusammen?
Haben Sie jetzt gerade gesagt, dass durch die Migration die Frage der Mieten bestimmt wird, das heißt, die Mieten sind höher bei?
Ich habe gesagt, dass am unteren Ende dort, wo Ihre Kundschaft sitzt, dass genau dort durch den Zuzug von sehr vielen Menschen und das ist ehrlich gesagt eine Binse, natürlich ein Konkurrenzkampf, ein harter Konkurrenzdruck um bezahlbaren Wohnraum entsteht. Genau das habe ich gesagt.
Aber dann kennen Sie sich nicht genau aus. Kennen Sie Sonneberg? Sonneberg, erster AfD-Landrat, höchster Anteil von AfD-Wählerinnen und Wählern. Die haben, ich glaube, 10 bis 20 Prozent Leerstandort. So. Dieser enge Zusammenhang, den Sie da machen.
Kein Argument von Berlin, keins für Hamburg und keins für die meisten.
Ich wohne in Hamburg St. Pauli und wollen Sie mir sagen, dass die Mieten in St. Pauli gestiegen sind, weil wir Migration haben? Die Mieten sind gestiegen, weil irgendwelche reichen Erben den letzten Fennig daraus pressen? Ja, Frau Prien, das ist der Unterschied zwischen CDU und Linke.
Und ich möchte nicht, dass irgendwelche reichen Erben, die Mieten so sich überwinden, dass die Leute aus der Stadt rausziehen müssen.
Ich finde, die Leute, die können sich die Mieten in St. Pauli nicht mal leisten, müssen raus aus der Stadt ziehen. Für ältere Leute ist das ein großes Thema, weil irgendwelche reichen Erben damit Porsche fahren wollen.
Wenn die Welt so einfach wäre, Herr von Acknend-Schulm, wäre es ja schön.
Nein, sie ist es eben nicht. Doch, sie könnten zum Beispiel in ihrer CDU-Regierung in Schleswig-Kreuzstein dafür sorgen, dass kein Grund und Boden mehr, dass nichts mehr an andere Privates geht als an Genossenschaften.
Das könnten wir, das wollen wir aber nicht, weil wir das hier grundsätzlich falsch halten.
Sie wollen, dass jemand von meiner Miete Porsche fährt und ich finde das falsch.
Oh, Porsche-Fahrt, das ist so platt, Herr von Acknend-Schulm. Ich dachte, es könnte ein netter Abend werden.
Haben Sie nicht legendäre Porsche-Fahrer in Ihren eigenen Reihen?
Nee, der ist bei PSV. Ah, okay. Okay, aber der war mal bei Ihnen.
Ist rechts abgewogen.
Ja, Markus Lanz, nicht interessiert. Sobald es um Thema Ungleichheit, Erbschaften, Immobilien geht, blockt er ab, will jetzt nochmal diese uralte Geschichte raus und das Klaus Ernst. Um den ging es jetzt gerade. Porsche fährt und darf man in der linken sein und Porsche fahren. Oh, oh, oh, wollen wir noch mal eine große Debatte und da irgendeine SPD-Abgeordnete auch eine Rolex tragen. Darüber will man lieber diskutieren, weil es ja exakt so ist, wie Jan van Aken es hier schildert. In Hamburg steigen die Mieten nicht, weil die Migranten gekommen sind.
Es ist nicht exakt so, wie Jan van Aken sagt, sondern es ist alles viel schlimmer. Es ist alles viel schlimmer. Dieses Buch von Julia Friedrichs, Crazy Rich, was wir gleich lesen im Salon, hat mich radikalisiert.
Ich wundere mich darüber sehr.
Warum?
Dass es dich radikalisiert hat, weil ich nicht den Eindruck hatte, dass das das Ziel dieses Buches ist.
Deswegen werde ich auch am Anfang eine andere Lesart vorschlagen.
Genau, dass das funktioniert hat, finde ich toll. Und dass du eine andere Lesart vorschlagen kannst auch, denn ich habe gewisse Einwände. Aber mich hat es auch radikalisiert, weil ich sagen würde, ne, so viel Geduld bringen wir jetzt mal nicht auf. Jetzt machen wir hier mal rein Tisch. Jedenfalls, das ist die mediale Diskussion, wie sie gerade geführt wird. Und dann lass uns doch überleiten zu dem Buch von Julia Friedrichs. Und da erinnerte ich mich an eine Landsendung. Einige Monate ist es her, da waren junge Politiker zu Gast, unter anderem auch der Juso-Chef Philipp Thürmer, der ja von Julia Friedrichs auch nochmal kritisiert wird in diesem Buch. Aber wir hören jetzt hier nochmal Lanz Einwand. Also es geht nochmal um die Superreichen. Und diese Frage, sollte es überhaupt Milliardäre in Deutschland geben? Thürmer sagt nein. Und wie ist denn das eigentlich, wenn die Privatjet fliegen, Yachten haben? Da sagt Thürmer, das ist doch nicht gerecht. Lanz?
Ich will nur einmal den Punkt kurz machen. Wenn jemand bereit ist, für ein Auto beispielsweise, ein Porsche 200.000 Euro auszugeben.
Soll er machen?
Wir reden von Mediaderinnen. Wie viele Arbeitsplätze sichert jemand, der in Deutschland eine Superjacht bestellt, wie sie sie gerade beschreiben? Ich glaube, da gibt es deutliches.
Ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt, die meisten Menschen im Land, wenn sie über Gerechtigkeit und Nachdenken...
Entschuldigung, würden Sie das bestreiten? Davon leben doch sehr viele Menschen. Dann im Zweifel.
Aber Herr Lanz, wer ist denn davon?
Muss nicht gleich übergeben.
Also ich glaube, wenn wir über das Thema Gerechtigkeit sprechen...
Da könnte man dem Geld woanders, gibt es viele gesellschaftliche Baustellen, wo man das Geld gut einsetzen könnte, wo Menschen auch Arbeit finden würden, wo man nicht darauf hinarbeitet, ein Produkt herzustellen.
Das ist ganz, ganz wenig.
Ja, wir haben die Superjachten, damit wir Menschen weiterhin Arbeitsplätze gewähren können. Denn sonst gibt es ja nichts zu tun im Land, wie wir wissen. Sonst müsste man ja irgendwie so unsinnige Dinge machen, wie die Bahn erneuern, Infrastruktur aufbauen. Nein, lasst uns bitte die vernünftigen Dinge priorisieren. Superjachten, Privatschatz, damit diese Arbeitsplätze erhalten bleiben.
Ja, also das Denken ist jetzt auf mehrfache Art und Weise zu zertrümmern. Dieses Buch Superrich behandelt jetzt Superreiche. Okay, da hat man erstmal so ein intuitives Verständnis von, die haben aber ganz schön viel Geld, wäre es nicht woanders besser aufgehoben und so. Das sind alles peripherere Fragen. Man kann es ruhig einmal noch grundsätzlicher machen und ich will noch mal so einen Brückenschlag auch zu dieser natürlichen Wahl. Wenn wir feststellen, dass 30 Prozent eines Bundeslandes AfD wählt und das eine klare Entwicklungsgeschichte ist, über mehrere inzwischen fast Jahrzehnte und mehrere Wahlen an unterschiedlichen Orten mit unterschiedlichen Ausprägungen. Und danach trifft man sich immer noch zum Politikpodcast oder bei Sandra Maischberger und versucht, ja, ja, können sie uns noch mal erklären, ich habe es immer noch nicht verstanden. Wie kann man denn die größte und wichtigste Entwicklung eines Landes einfach so abhandeln? Ich habe es nicht verstanden, können sie es noch mal erklären? Ich habe es irgendwie nicht verstanden. So und wenn dann irgendwelche Leute nach dem Jahrzehnte lang das Management Magazine Listen mit Reichen aufführt, plötzlich feststellt, wir haben da ein Vermögen übersehen. Ach so, ist Platz eins. Haben wir nicht gewusst. Wir haben einfach die reichste Familie des Landes übersehen.
Weil die Daten nicht da waren.
Das geht nicht, gell?
Also nicht, weil das Management Magazine schlampig war, sondern weil die Daten nicht da sind.
Genau. Kein Journalist kann darüber Bescheid wissen, weil es diese grundlegenden, wo kann ich dann mal nachschauen, einfach nicht gibt. Irgendwelche Leute machen das als Hobby und finden dann 50 Milliarden Vermögen. Das ist doch bescheuert. Also lieber Journalismus. Wenn große Entwicklungen da sind oder Superjachten besonders groß sind, die Antwort ist nicht, ja, das sind Arbeitsplätze. Arbeitsplätze kann von mir aus gerne vor 20 Jahren Gerhard Schröder gesagt haben, als Kaufhof das erste Mal von Amazon bedroht wurde. Das war damals wirklich neu, okay, aber die Arbeitsplätze, das ist wirklich nicht darum geht es hier gar nicht. Ja, auf so einer 100 Meter langen Yacht für elf Leute arbeiten 36, aber die 36 verbuchen wir hier nicht unter Arbeitsplätze. Das ist aber bescheuert.
Wir sprechen also im Salon über Crazy Rich, die geheime Welt der Superreichen von Julia Friedrichs. Es ist ein Buch, das auch mit Milliardären spricht, mit Erben spricht.
Ein Spektakel, das trinkt gleich ein Feuerwerk ab.
Mit Leuten, die sehr lange recherchiert haben, um überhaupt mal herauszufinden, wie viel Vermögen gibt es. Ich will noch eine andere Perspektive, nämlich die Perspektive von unten dann einbringen, nämlich stelle ich den Roman Mein Name ist Estella vor von Aliyah Trabuco Serran, eine chilenische Autorin, die aus der Perspektive einer Haushälterin, die in einer vermögenden Familie arbeitet, berichtet. Und dieser Monolog, der dazu Gehör gebracht wird, ist ganz, ganz erstaunlich. Dann werde ich mich, wie schon angekündigt, mit dem Text Angst und Politik von Franz Neumann auseinandersetzen. Ich glaube, dass der uns einige Hinweise gibt, wie wir heute mit Angst und Politik umgehen. Außerdem haben wir noch einen Artikel über die prekären Wohnungsmärkte und es wird in einem Essay aus dem New Yorker darum gehen, dass KI niemals Kunst machen wird.
Okay.
Das ist also etwas, worauf du dich freuen kannst. Und ich habe ausnahmsweise dann nicht noch einen weiteren Text mitgebracht, sondern mal einen CD-Tipp oder ihr jungen Leute, ihr hört es ja über Spotify oder so. Man kann es natürlich auch da dann abkürzen.
Da fällst du gleich, wenn auch nur in einzelnen Endungen, in den bayerischen Bergbewohner.
Okay.
Wir lesen meinerseits Texte, die sich mit Thüringen befassen, ohne dass sie von Thüringen handeln. Die Autoren wissen nicht mal, wo Thüringen liegt. Keiner der Protagonisten hat irgendwas mit Thüringen zu tun, aber trotzdem für uns über diese peripherale Bande entscheidend. Alles aus der New York Times ist mir erst aufgefallen, als ich alle drei Texte zusammengestellt hatte, dass alles New York Times war. Aber liebe deutsche Journalisten, wenn ihr nicht weiter wisst, und ich sage euch, ihr wisst offenbar gerade nicht weiter, übersetzt die New York Times. Und damit meine ich nicht einfach nur Deep-L benutzen, sondern tauscht noch mal die Themen zu den Problemen, die da verhandelt werden, aus. Wir haben genau dieselben. Also und so ungefähr lesen wir diese Texte. Zum einen geht es darum, um die Frage, was hat es mit diesem ich fühle mich abgemeldet Gefühl auf sich? Warum fühlen sich Menschen abgemeldet? Und was bedeutet das? Und dann schauen wir uns mal an in Amerika. Das ist wirklich interessant. Die Überschrift lautet, in dieser Demokratie hat man alles außer einer Wahl. Und ich will nur mal die Zahlen nennen. Qualitativ werden wir es dann ausführen. In Amerika sind sehr viele Wahlämter. Der Sheriff, der Staatsanwalt, keine Ahnung, was auch immer. In der Hälfte dieser Wahlen gibt es keine Konkurrenz. Also es steht einfach ein Name und dann kürzt man den halt an und dann war's das. So, leider 7% Wahlbeteiligung, fertig. Also wirklich crazy. Und die BBC, ich dachte mir, wenn wir heute mit Crazy Rich Stößen sind, brauchen wir was Entspanntes. Aus der Liste der 100 wichtigsten Nahrungsmittel, die es gibt, die man unverarbeitet essen kann, gehen wir kurz die 30 Top-Platzierung durch.
Prima.
Es ist nicht wirklich ein Journalismus, sondern die BBC hat da so eine Agentur bei Auftrag, mal Wissenschaft auszuwerten und, aber ich fand ihr überraschend, was auf Platz 1 steht. Also manchmal kann es die Welt so einfach sein.
Nutella? Nein.
Ja Nutella. Es geht um unverarbeitete Lebensmittel. Ich lasse es als Teaser offen.
Gut, dann können wir uns also gleich im Salon sehen. Der Salon ist ganz einfach zu buchen. Für drei Euro im Monat geht es los. Und zwar kann man das über Steady machen, denn am einfachsten ist es, man geht jetzt auf die Seite neuezwanziger.de. Dort ist ein goldener Salon-Button. Wenn man darauf klickt, dann bekommt man die verschiedenen Steady-Pakete angezeigt und kann dann eines buchen. Wer bei Patreon schon ist und dort das lieber hören möchte, kann das auch über Patreon tun. Wer das über Apple hören möchte, weil es ein bisschen praktischer ist und es nicht stört, dass es da ein bisschen teurer ist, weil Apple natürlich eine eigene Gebühr noch mal haben will, kann es auch direkt über Apple buchen. Wer uns jetzt gerade bei Spotify hört, kann auch jetzt dann dort das Bezahl-Abo anklicken. Dann wird man auch zu Steady weitergeleitet. Und es lohnt sich in diesem Monat doppelt, denn wir haben ja noch einen Live-Salon vor uns.
Und wer denkt, oh, dieser Söder, der redet ja ganz schön blöd über diese Migranten. Muss das denn sein? Der soll mal abwarten, wie ich gleich über die Superreichen rede.
Gut, bis gleich.
Bis gleich.